Kids... killed kids. It's not fun, and so desensitizes what we have to do because that is our job. It's a job.
>> Against that wall, with the 'X' on it, can I have all my veterans?
The other wall, on this side, I'm gonna have all my peace activists.
>> The military brainwashes its soldiers.
>> Veteran: (quietly) How?
>> Oh, wow.
Um, I don't think the natural inclination for a human being is to want to kill another human being.
There is a necessary requirement in the military to get you to perform a certain action.
And in order for that action to occur, it is my theory, that there is a
part of changing the way that you think,
in order to take somebody from a human being and make it a target so that you can achieve a goal.
They had asked are the military
Desensitizing soldiers are they
Manipulating them mentally and I would have walked over. I would have
Brainwashed we chose it. Well. I don't know man
It's just like I even watch like the advertisements for the military
And it just seems to me the one thing you brought up was was killing
It's no no one wants to do. I know. I don't want to do. I know I didn't want to flips you yes
He was use the words desensitized. We're desensitizes and so because we have to we have to move on
I just think that that's kind of my point though in order to get from that spot where you don't want to kill another human
Being to where you look at it as this is just my job, but it's a choice. Yeah, it's not brainwashed
It really just comes down to either that guy at the end of your muzzle
Or you and I want to come back home to my family
Okay
Yeah, this is a tough one I
think that there's a point between a just war and
An unjust war there are certain wars that?
You know, maybe we should have gone into it like maybe we shouldn't have gone into Iraq
Right and then there's certain wars where World War two
You know where Hitler was
Advancing to pull in I think that's definitely a just war to get into I mean he was trying to kill Jewish people yeah
And in that case you could call it a necessary evil
There is a time that that necessary evil has to happen and in that you don't even maybe call it a necessary evil
It's just a necessity the action itself has to take place
As long as we leave this on the table at war is a necessary evil it really just excuses almost all
You know all wars because if it's six - what's excusable right when does it become necessary?
If you really want to see a peaceful world you have to just get rid of that because the key word there is it necessary
Necessary I don't believe that I don't believe it's necessary that it's the only way for to you to obtain your objective is war
Do you I thought you were disagreeing with the evil no no no, I mean well. Yeah war is not evil I mean
not yeah, it's not
Have you ever had an argument, but you had good intentions?
Right so yeah to speak on the word evil. I don't really agree that war equals evil as well
Probable maybe not possible
Yes, yeah
When you get humans together and find a way to find common ground to find the similarities rather than the differences
That's when you have a possibility
At peace and I believe that it is something that is possible on a grand scale is it easy
Maybe not but it is possible
World peace I want that to happen of course
But it's so much easier said than done
I think because just the way that we were taught you know we all want world peace
But let's say a culture in Africa thinks that genital mutilation is perfectly fine
Are we going to be perfectly fine with that are we going to be able to talk them out of it?
I don't really think we are because they have their own customs their own cultures
So the only way we can kind of get them to accept our culture. Is there is some sort of violence
That's dangerous. I do believe that the
Quantum of people that would prefer peace to conflict is growing and that's what gives me hope
So if it meant if I died the world would be at peace oh
Yeah
Look I've I've had some amazing adventures on planet earth
I've had the greatest of friends the greatest of family seen the best concerts seen some beautiful places if it meant that
That happened for this place to be a-ok groovy do it right now. I had a good run
I got 35 years with more than a lot
I've got more than twice yeah, those ears
But more importantly I have two grandchildren and a third one on the way, yeah
and and really I had to think about it, but if I could do that and bring them world peace let alone all the
Lexi's and Charlie's around the world that's easy and like life is so beautiful, but for me
I believe there is a life after my life, and there are many lifetimes. Yeah, if I had to die for world peace
me versus 7 billion human beings
Question
I initially when I heard the question. I thought man
What a dumb question and then Steve your answer actually really made me think yeah
Well actually elicited like a really beautiful response. Are you talking about your grandchildren you know and then I'm
Like I'll think a little bit more about this question
And I realized you know what if I say I'm willing to die for peace. Oh gosh. What's the last time?
I did anything to actually promote peace. Oh, I'd be a claw
I'd be a really full of shit if I said that I would be willing to die for peace
I wouldn't be able. Do you even take the most basic steps towards actually contributing something, but those basic those basic steps totally matter
But also living a life of purpose is a life
That's lived a moment to moment to moment so simply you by being you you affect people like yeah you seem
I only met you for what half an hour 45 minutes
You got a good head on your shoulders and wherever you go you leave an imprint
And that's true for all of us. I mean don't get me wrong. I don't want to die, and I'd rather do those things I
I'm in a I'm in a peace group that has met every Friday morning since 9/11
16 years for two hours every Friday to work on these issues
So I think really if we I sometimes say a dollar a day and an hour a day
Yeah, I know a lot of I mean not like tons of people was you know dozen or so people with that my closest friend
To kill was killed was his name is Chris domain and he had a wife and kids it was is
Pretty sad I've deployed seven times now, and I'm scheduled to go back out in March
For my eighth back to Afghanistan, but uh I think there was probably one or two deployments where we didn't
Lose someone. I don't know if it's appropriate what taps into your
Courage to keep going back in the face of losing these guys. Yeah, it's a
For me. It's not only just a job when I say job. I think of family
I think of putting food on the table roof over the head of my family and then
Second to that or pretty much tied for first is the guys next to you you know
Which eyes go out here in LA and really?
They have a future in college or anything just we've got poor and homeless at some points
But uh join the military I want to serve my country and really just have some stable and has it evolved
It was now's like this big family. You're part of you're part of something that's bigger, and I don't mind
deploying because I know I'm with family I
Think I'm blessed that I don't know anybody who's died in combat so I mean yeah
I don't understand what you guys have been through but I applaud you all of you guys for
Like you said putting food on the table cuz in my head. I was like. There's so many jobs out there. Why this one
When you're when you're a soldier, you're you're making a sacrifice, so thank you
You're welcome
Yeah, you know I mean I think and I think as Americans we appreciate anybody who makes a significant sacrifice
Its kind of the ultimate sacrifice
So
Thank you for checking out that video much appreciation
We get to do what we love because you all watch our videos
So if you really love us you'll continue to keep watching videos
There's more right here that you can check out you probably haven't seen all of them
And if you really want to just commit to us you can subscribe right here. I'll be around
I'll be at the end of some more videos, and I will keep in touch peace
You